so the failed former president Donald
Trump has been caught in another lie
thanks to some newly released audio
tapes from uh related to Maggie
haberman's forthcoming book these are
audio recordings of interviews that
Maggie Haberman from The New York Times
Did for this book that is forthcoming
and in this first clip that we're going
to look at Donald Trump tells Maggie
Haberman he didn't watch the the Trump
riots on January 6 2021 on TV he wasn't
watching it as it unfolded he eventually
heard about it from other people and
much later turned on the TV just for a
moment now of course we know that this
is a lie multiple Trump aides testified
before Congress under oath that Donald
Trump was watching the entire thing and
of course it's logical that he was he
went to the Capitol gave this wacky
speech people immediately started
walking to the Capitol he wanted to go
to the Capitol he was instead brought to
the White House and he sat there
watching TV the entire day but needless
to say he tries to lie here and say no
oh no I I wasn't that interesting no
someone had to tell me about it I was
busy doing what he hadn't been doing
work for months at that point but what
were you doing when when how did you
find out that that there were people
storming the capital I had heard that
afterwards and actually on the late side
very late very late I was I was having
meetings I was also with Mark Meadows
and others by the way the mention of
Mark Meadows makes it even less
believable because we know from the
testimony of multiple other witnesses
that Mark Meadows was a hundred and ten
percent engaged with the riots begging
Trump to do something and in touch with
Cassidy you know all these the The
Mention Of Meadows makes this even less
believable it was already not believable
I was not watching television I didn't
need the television you weren't okay I
didn't usually have that the television
on I'd have it on if there was something
and of course that's where Trump goes
too far Trump had the TV on all the time
in fact he would sometimes have have it
on during meetings and it would distract
him I then later turned it on and I saw
what was happening I also had a
confidence that
the capital who didn't want these 10 000
people Capital police he meant that
they'd be able to control this thing and
you don't realize that you know they
they did lose control
so what Trump says there it just wasn't
true on two fronts that there were AIDS
around him at that time who have
testified to the house select committee
that he indeed was watching television
during that period he would have seen
the capital falling to his supporters
and also the Capitol Police were clearly
overwhelmed by the Trump supporters yeah
so it's all lies and we've we've talked
about it there's widespread reporting uh
Reuters Trump watched January 6 Capital
Riot unfold on TV ignored pleased to
call for peace the entire day afternoon
was Trump watching it and then initially
thinking that it was great and then
later people urging him to do something
about it Trump's starting to become
upset that the rioters were coming off
as so low brow they didn't exactly seem
like high-class people was a concern for
Trump as that was going on and we know
that it was all lie after lie after lie
now there's one other clip here this is
pretty interesting now in the context of
the Marvel Lago raid Donald Trump was
asked about by Maggie Haberman in these
recordings about taking stuff from the
White House and it's all just kind of
weird the language is weird again nation
that you had with Donald Trump where you
brought up
the correspondence he had with North
Korean leader Kim Jong and the New York
Times released audio of this now we have
audio of this conversation so let's
listen
did you leave the White House with
anything in particular were there any
Memento documents you took with you
anything
nothing of great urgency okay I have
great things there you know the letters
to Kim Jong-un letters and many of them
you were able to take those with you
look at what's happening wow those are
the love letters I think that has the I
think that's in the archives but most of
it is in the earth okay but the Kim
Jong-un was we have incredible things I
have incredible letters with other
leaders
okay so at least there Donald Trump not
admitting that a whole bunch of
different stuff was taken and it was at
his house of course that interview was
from uh that interview was was from
about a year ago and uh so that is
something that is particularly
interesting at this point in time wild
stuff but even in private conversations
Trump lies because Trump lies all the
time and we know that
one of our sponsors today is Bluetooth a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month's supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence when
it's time all you have to do is take a
short quiz on their website a licensed
doctor approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code Pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping